what's the deal with airplan
peanuts he's got a family I think the
family can keep you relatable too you
have a family kids are always relable
everyone raised a kid talk about
struggle I mean kids are hell I'm going
to have a kid just for the material it's
just going to help my career I'm going
to lose a kid just for the
materity hard to wrestle an hour oh yeah
dude oh I can't even make love for 11
minutes
yeah to be honest with you
so so yeah you put me against another
man I can't do an hour bro you know no
matter what city we're in I better keep
you overnight in Tampa Tonight
brother I could them people can help you
out with
that I I don't know
dude I don't know man my friend deck
Murdock went told me to start one time
the girl said hey what about me he said
hey we both start at the same time I
can't help it if you can't keep
up rudyy sorry what cleaning supplies
were you supposed to get at the house um
soap soap dish soap soap two soaps soap
soap soap soap no no in Phil in
Philippines soap soap is one soap soap
soap that's one soap what do you know
what soap soap and sabano soap soap and
sabano let me ask you something you're
questioning a white man what soap is
soap soap soap soap oh my bad soap soap
sorry not soap soup soup oh it's bat
soup no it's lobster bisque and french
onion soup right in one bowl two part
one it's not a food it's like what you
it's like an action soap soap oh I know
what it is what it's when you stab
somebody with a machete no soap
no yeah one soap one soap it's an action
soap soap soap soap soap soap not soap
soap soap soap soap soap oh jumping
jacks no soap soap soap soap soap soap
that doesn't sound like that no no no no
uh jump rope it's an action no it's jump
rope oh soap soap soap I get it it's not
it's not it's an action Bob is it an
action it's it's you know how you know
how close to it you're close to it oh
it's going down on someone it's a thick
dick loose
vagina it's an echo yeah there's an echo
there it's eating ass cuz somebody goes
oh this needs
soap what is it look at us back in it
just like we always did it to you know
what dude there what is that there's two
o's and there's two zeros they're on
that side of the table
biggest nuggets fan nuggets fan number
one yeah baby I'm a big LSU baseball
game always have does she go to LSU liby
dun stop trying to bring up
[__] are you in your mind dude your
career is Livy dun
are I just can't imagine this is worth
maybe a lawsuit no I think those girls
hate her she's probably a [__] because
you have to be to be this Arena Global
household name
thing yeah so you got to you got to snap
you know hey do that you got to crack
the whip a little but but do you well
let me let me ask you something I mean
like for instance Bert okay Bert's doing
this gigantic tour I'm not saying he's a
nice guy yeah but I'm not saying that
he's at lizzo's level but same
body post Malone meat roast Malone
what's up boy your ass look like an
unemployed crocodile huny [__]
[Laughter]
look at Tony boy you look like a gay
Clansman [__] put that hood
on well I basically anytime I'm around
you I feel like a gay Clan yeah boy you
look like a you look like a gay gallon
of milk [__] your
ass that [__] full of semen [__] oh my
God coming on strong look at Kurt mes
boy you look like a useless X-Man [__]
yo your special power hey his special
pow is that his uh toenails get real
long
[__] I noticed you didn't do Joe that's
my daddy man I can't my daddy man a bald
David finally found his dad
[Applause]
everybody
I did see Oppenheimer and listen you you
walked out too right I didn't walk out I
watched the whole thing but it was mid
if I'm being
honest it's like Interstellar comes back
later and you're like that's a
phenomenal no Interstellar was great
from the beginning to the end first
first time watching Interstellar was
first first 20 were is slow I here's the
thing I love being confused in a film if
you can make confuse me I love it my
favor thing about I like make a perfect
didn't
firstus does anyone care what I have to
say about movies like like this made
this made way too many headlines that I
walked out of Oppenheimer who gives a
when I think about these movies they
care bro no it's just stupid bro why am
I like the but don't you have to say
that because of what happened to you in
Japan bro come
on don't you have to be like I knew
going I knew you were going there this
movie stinks
like I
did I did find sorry I'm s i I thought I
did think it was a little culturally
insensitive and I have a lot of thoughts
on this one I think you're right
America's become high school and and you
know lizo is the new drama of the prom
queen or whatever of the day and so
everybody's all over it and then you go
actually this happened and people go
what no and they're just going off a
headline two I forgot my other thought
if it'll come it'll come back it'll come
it's in there you just got you got 50
million jokes there I got it I got it
there It Is Well I think uh you got to
keep upping it you got to keep upping
the drama cuz like we have aliens here
right Congress admitted it and no one
gives a because we're like what aliens
we're on this true crime [__] right now
this is way more fun you're like but
there's a martian in Phoenix and they're
like ah this lady killed her husband and
her dog and all that you're like that's
way more salacious you're like but this
is a martian from another land and
they're like ah when the Martian saids
something racist call me now we're
talking so we're we're so we it's like
we're beaked up you know you start with
weed then you go to pills then you go to
heroin we're all in the heroin phase of
the news and we can't go back to the
weed I never thought of that that's why
martians are boring they're boring
they're not murdering any women yes that
would put them on the map there's no
safe way to consume that fear misgender
someone you Martian and now you'll get
in the news I think this is fake do you
guys think this is fake this woman is
creating a new gender and she identifies
as Trans financial for me it's clearly
fake and just she's doing a bit but
people are getting actually mad at her
in the comments you he here she goes so
I identify as Trends Financial which
means that I am a rich girl stuck in a
brook go body and that is one of the
hottest things that I have to deal with
in
life hardest get the get out of here
it's a bit but I but but the thing is
but the thing is with this is people now
like on the comments like they really
are taking this seriously and they're
like is this just another kind of thing
now we have to you know not disrespect
oh I get it cuz I'm transatlantic I feel
like I have to fly to Europe but I don't
want to I don't want to right right
Trans financial sounds like a really
exclusive Bank
exactly accept kayin Jenner she's it
sounds like like like like like a
stadium tour on Bert's fully loaded tour
he's doing Trans Financial
Field there's never going to be a moment
where I'm like let me carry a suit on
the seven train well we do have uh
things now like a task rabbit have you
heard of this I have yeah you can just
find a guy and go I'll give you 60 bucks
you go to Midtown and bring my suit to a
story a case closed and there's a guy
out there some pothead with a mullet's
going to go I'll do it okay see like
come on my shirt or anything like that
if you give him another five what what
did that guy say to you earlier oh yeah
true big man's back on campus dude big
man's back on
campus I've been in my old stomping
grounds in
Westchester that was devastating I was
so yo dude what's up man big man's back
on
campus don't say that in front of my
friends dude I thought that was I
thought he was being funny there's no
chance that's the funniest [__] anyone
could ever if he was being funny it was
but he was not it was I could I could
read his nervous enity he was with his
babe he was just like I I believe it was
it was serious man big man's back on
campus was the funniest [__] I've heard
all night yeah he like what's up man he
like big man's back on campus just from
like 5 feet away beast beast yeah that
was nice absolute Beast you know who you
are dude I mean it's true dude I mean it
is the
bmoc the bmoc has returned the return of
the bmlc you got her the last night
you're here just go [__] nuts dude I
mean yeah no problem I mean if you say
so I guess I will I will go wild let's
do a little G request thing okay I'll
bring my guitar you bring the songs
let's have some fun Bop plop yeah so is
if you don't know this pretty much
everybody's blocked now
um literally we're all blocked I think
that by the way he must have hired
somebody new knew you know what I mean
like youngster somebody came in got to
block these folks he's like oh and then
he was like uh what is it like two dozen
people and he was
like no by the way the entire y Studios
has zero
access uh to the G account and here's
what I can say this is not the time to
back
down we need you to step up where we
can't right support our c you're going
to be weak or you're going to be strong
your brothers are sitting here just
waiting for
the Hella
Evac we don't have food we don't have
water you going to leave us here or you
going to step up just something to think
about are you motivating your soldiers
like your your buddy H did give us a
speech give us a motivational speech
Jesus Christ and you put in three egg
yolks over two other eggs but look how
many ingredients are in there with
pancakes you got a pan and a cake and
that's it feels wrong it feels great
pancakes made rter a little more
complicated than you think dude you're
dealing with baking soda baking flour or
powder you're dealing with a with a
flour you're dealing with sometimes a
cinnamon some vanilla extract and a chef
who has to put it together which means
it's done by a professional pancakes you
can do it you can do it no I'm saying
everything I just have you ever tried to
make pancakes it is no walk in the
[Music]
park I can just get his it is no walk in
the park by the way Evan thank you for
dressing like a Latino T-Mobile employee
on date
night we got a plan for you okay you
come in here lady can you look like a
Dominican a Dominican taking out his
side [__] for
margaritas I have a feeling before the
end of this podcast I'm going to buy a
Mazda cx30 off of this
guy I do like I take a side [__] to a
basketball game when we're on the jumbo
sh noral way dude
yeah oh I just came from an event I know
dude it was a magician's
convention he came straight here he was
trying to be the gay assistant he he
came straight from the cloud of smoke
all the way to his story what don't you
like I don't like Jews he said it you
heard him say it that was Joe list not
you heard what he said um no I like I
like uh there's got to be a Jew that's a
good musician Jean Simmons I do hate but
um what's it called Beasty Boys I'm not
big really I don't love them but mod
Yahoo you're a big modest Yahoo fan I
don't know who that is you remember that
guy he had a you remember that guy he
had he had a one hit he had like a one
hit Reay hipop Joey rone Joey raone he's
Jewish thank God we got I was going to
be I was nervous for you for a I was
like dude there's a bunch out there you
just don't know you know what I mean
yeah all right who's your favorite
Palestinian artist Cat Stevens he uh he
he converted converted love Cat Stevens
he converted to Islam and hated America
or something like that I have a question
I got asked cuz you might be the only
one who can answer this okay you just
said it you were buddies with Jacko
right Jackson Michael Jackson yeah yeah
you were at the Neverland Ranch I'm
assuming can you tell this audience once
and for all
what the
[Music]
term means yes it's an exuberant feeling
of
Self
Indulgence on the Dance Floor
specifically that's it yeah how does it
go it's a
code you got to finish with the who
because you don't do the who afterwards
is it or is it I thought it was with a
CH no what is it
no I think it's no no you're thinking of
Shaman shamon shamon shamon shamon
what's Shimon well it's Kon but it's
like slang you know it's like so he
changed Kon that's all it is to Shimon
it's simple it's you know that's genius
right it's just that one fine little
detail that changes it no it changes it
from genius to stupid you see
than no but but but because he said
shamon that made it genius again yeah
see if it was Jamon you know or
something like that then pretty stupid
but Shamone Shone I mean that says a lot
what was some of the other ones he had
he had shei she it's not shei what is
this are you obsessed with something is
there something else we need to get out
here if you if you if you sing it out
it's
clearly no there's no she there's no she
in there not she she wait a minute not
she he in today's world yeah with with
he and she you got to have a he don't
start don't start she no
shimone sounds like someone yelling for
a kid to come in to do
shimone I'll be in in a minute damn it
come on in for n fix hey I'm fixing up
the table downstair now I'll be up there
in a minute you know his dog tattoo
story he was at skankfest on mushrooms
and he got a dog tattooed on
it was it was acid and I got dog tattoo
on me and it sucks but it's also in like
the weirdest spot you could ever get a
tattoo I didn't see it it's crazy how
bad it is oh I see it now yeah I mean
it's it looks like a pizza and a dog
it's so big I can't even it looks like
somebody colored it in with B Mar I know
dude I know I can't even I can't do
anything it to you some [__] some
jail yeah they should be in jail that's
crazy was a good guy I was just uh I was
just like too high on acid to say no
were you the were since you were on acid
you were like
bigger I make it
suck make it suck make it horrible I
hate myself so can you move it and make
them you know do tricks he does nothing
oh okay there you go he does nothing oh
oh he's getting he's
excited we're rolling baby hey get right
in get right in you have started already
yeah dude the only thing the only thing
it was missing is the glasses look at
this the mirror
image get down dude yeah what's up did
look familiar yeah dude yeah
dude dude I saw that in the mirror this
morning I bro it literally when they
brought this out I was like what what is
the pig's name again Abby I was like
dude I'm calling it Joe and it every
time you called Joe it snorts you comedy
podcasting stats from August Joe list
made the most guest appearances last
month going on eight total podcasts
including are you garbage the Honeydew
taste buds stav's world we might be
drunk whiskey Ginger the verzy effect
and Legion of skanks the three most
viewed episodes from last month were
flagrance episode with that Mexican OT
at 2.4 million views right behind that
one was kill Tony's episode featuring
post Malone and Joe Rogan which hit 1.4
million views in just 3 days also
theovon and this past weekend just
posted their episode with Jordan
Peterson which already hit a million in
Just 2 days be sure to subscribe to joke
world right now if you enjoyed this
monthly wrap-up and want to stay in the
loop with the comedy world and to truly
never miss anything happening with all
your favorite comedians tune in to our
weekly comedy news show every Tuesday
and thank you for
watching joke
world that's did it J
world and it world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out